first off just real quick Josh congrats
on the wedding how are you feeling I
feel great I feel great look at that
nice
love it
um so mighty Ducks I mean Lauren you
know the thing I think people connect
with so much about this story is that
it's an Underdog Story but how would you
describe the Mighty Ducks going into
this new season and what do you think it
is about underdogs that people just
really connect with
um I think that going into the season we
might think of ourselves as less of
under uh not so underdoggy if we can say
that uh as we were until we meet our
match in Josh's character and his
um Camp which he insists is not a camp
um like it's sort of the game is is
upped to a degree we didn't even really
know existed and we you know think we're
going to have just like a fun summer
adventure and it turns out to be a lot
more challenging so we're still kind of
the Misfits we're still kind of like the
kids who don't exactly fit in which I
think people relate to because no matter
how good an athlete or how cool a person
we've all felt that way at some point
that like we don't fit in or we don't
quite we can't quite work at the level
we want to I just think that's really
um
relatable
absolutely and Josh how has it been
joining season two and I know you had
some hockey experience going into this
but how was it sort of getting back on
that ice I think I read somewhere that
you like puked or something after how
was it
well I played hockey up until seventh
grade so I played for seven or eight
years growing up and uh
and then took a 33 year break
and got back on the ice when I knew I
was gonna be you know playing a former
professional hockey player and it's not
like riding a bicycle it's more like
riding a unicycle
and and trying to get trying to get you
know the the the you know those muscles
back it's just a totally different way
form of exercise and I went out there
got my skates
the strapped on got my stuff on went on
the ice three or four minutes into it I
was completely gassed so much so that I
had to leave the ice and go out and
throw up in the garbage can
and it was it was like I was like I were
I and I try to keep in pretty good shape
usually but this was like something that
I was just I don't know if I was trying
too hard
or or I was I wanted them to know that I
did play hockey at one point it just did
not go well and I literally ralphed uh
about three minutes in
anyway it was good that's method acting
I did get to get back into hockey though
which was fun you know
come you know the thing
The Thing Worth that the two of you guys
had how much fun was that for you guys
on set having this sort of like it's
almost felt like a game of tennis or
something really fun I just enjoyed
every scene we had and I enjoyed
um having Josh join the cast we we just
do have a very fun that's a fun dynamic
between those two characters she's like
hey lighten up and he's like take it
more seriously and that's just a good
you know conflict to have and um just
you know it was just a lot of fun to
make fun of him
of joy
and my my wife now was my fiance at the
time could not be a bigger Lorelei fan
so sweet she was she was more excited
about me taking this job than I was
and she's still pissed that she hasn't
got a chance to meet Lauren yet she's
like
what the heck
you know Mighty Ducks last season this
season come back any as a Canadian you
know Joshua Jackson can we see him
possibly make a return
we could possibly see him
will we could possibly not as well
that's what possibility means it could
really go either way
um and Josh how familiar were you with
the Mighty Ducks like both the films and
then the show before joining
I grew up watching this stuff
um
I love I mean because it was it was in
Minnesota it was based in Minnesota it
was about hockey and where I'm from is
really it's the hockey is in people's
blood it's almost like not quite as much
so as Canada but hockey in North Dakota
is a big deal and so this one sort of
spoke to us uh in a lot of ways because
it was close to home it was about hockey
uh it was fun it was funny uh so yes it
was part of my my childhood
um
and you know getting a chance to be a
part of it was was really really fun I
was not expecting to have such an
awesome time doing this and I was a
little nervous about you know taking
over the spot because Emilio had done
such a beautiful job all those years uh
thankful this character was much
different than than his and so I got to
kind of make it my own but you know
working with Lauren uh who's an absolute
Pro uh I knew I was gonna have to be on
my a game when I showed it to work uh
and then these kids were just
phenomenal so talented so funny and such
a such good little humans you know
they're they're young adults now but
they're just amazing amazing kids you'd
like to have more fun this year I mean
you know with things lightening up in
general
um but it's it it really you do feel
proud of these kids you know to see how
they handle these are these are hard
jobs you know and they um they're such a
great Ensemble they're really a joy to
be around and they adore Josh and he it
should be coaching and fathering lots
and lots of children because he's really
but I'm just basically another kid who
just wanted
Lauren just babysat all of us